police say they will not charge a
Florida man for killing another man in a
parking lot after an argument
surveillance video shows Michael Draco
was pushed over by Marquis McLaughlin
and responded with a single gun shot
Florida's Stand Your Ground law allows
people to respond with deadly force when
they believe their lives are in danger
protestors gathered at the scene
yesterday demanding justice for
mclaughlin Nagala burr who's in
clearwater florida spoke to his
girlfriend meg good morning
John good morning as you can see there's
a small memorial outside the store for
McLaughlin the family had parked in this
handicapped spot McLaughlin took his
five-year-old son II inside to buy
snacks less than three minutes later he
was gunned down for parking here
illegally he just tried to protect me
his kids
Brittany Jacob saw her boyfriend of nine
years Marquis McLaughlin shot and killed
in front of her last Thursday they went
to a convenience store with their three
children
McLaughlin walked inside with their
five-year-old son that's when Michael
Drake approached Jacobs
she says he berated her for parking in a
handicap spot without a permit do you
wanted me to you know move my car but
you know I had my right to party
anywhere I want to park surveillance but
it shows McLaughlin walk out of the
store in shoved rekha to the ground
seconds later Drake up pulled out his
gun and fired a single shot into
McLaughlin's chest the 28 year old
stumbled back into the store and
collapsed in front of his son what did
he take from you
my soul you know my partner you know we
did everything together no Drake ax has
a concealed weapons permit and told
police he shot McLaughlin because he
feared for his life
the Sheriff's Office says he is
protected by Florida's Stand Your Ground
law which allows people to use deadly
force when fearing imminent death or
great bodily harm without a duty to try
to escape the danger he had to shoot to
defend himself you know and those are
the facts and that's the law
but Jacob says McLaughlin backed away
from Drake after he pushed him this is
wrong because all my man was trying to
do is protect his girl like anybody else
would
the couple's four month old son in three
year old daughter were inside the car
during the shooting Jacobs told me that
she learned Drake ax wouldn't be charged
from the news CBS News has not been able
to reach Drake up for comment the State
Attorney's Office will have the final
say on whether to press charges
gaile all right thank you very much meg